hey what is up guys I'm KB HD here and
this is a Sony PlayStation 4 and this is
a Microsoft Xbox one and this what
you're watching is a comparison video of
initial impressions between the two now
this is also coming from a different
perspective probably more of a rare
perspective of someone who's doing this
type of video I am someone who has never
owned get this never owned a video game
console in my life I've played some
console games but I've never owned a
video game console so this video comes
from a different sort of perspective and
for me these aren't just next-generation
consoles these are the only generation
consoles and the only options between
deciding between one of the others so
I'm going to go over the pros and cons
for me in my initial impressions and
what I'm getting is a sort of vibe from
these companies as they advertise them
and maybe you'll get something out of it
basically the things I want to showcase
you guys are the designs of them and the
actual hardware both on the inside and
the outside because other things you
actually have to consider in terms of
design is clear that one of them is way
smaller than the other the ps4 from Sony
way smaller but what I noticed is I've
actually a pretty sweet matte plus
glossy design going on here you may or
may not like that I actually like matte
black electronics but there's quite a
lot of matte black plus velocity black
on both of these consoles when you look
at the controllers you also get a sort
of a sort of parallel between the sizes
of them because again the ps4 controller
from Sony it's always been smaller on
the PlayStation side and larger on the
Xbox side and to get exactly the same
here you have a larger controller for
the Xbox and smaller to the ps4 but in
terms of actually usability well I guess
it's a toss-up if you're already used to
the size and the shape of the Xbox 360
controller you'll love the new Xbox one
controller it's the same natural upgrade
with the same layout but the PlayStation
controller will take some getting used
to if you want to switch to that same if
you're it's the other way around the
layout of the new ps4 Dual Shock
controller is the exact same as the
layout of the ps3 controller just with
some economic improvements but if you
want to switch from ps3 to Xbox one
again that will require a bit of a
learning curve now looking at the actual
inside of these consoles you can also
read that there is a difference in terms
of graphical power between these two
consoles you'll find that actually the
PlayStation is a little bit more
graphically powerful in terms
just a physical hardware then the Xbox
one at the moment now right now you're
not actually going to be able to notice
this in fact in terms of the user
interface or just browsing around things
launching games closing games
multitasking web browsing you're not
going to find a huge difference in
performance because of that power but
these are consoles and consoles aren't
like phones or tablets where you might
see a new model every year or two years
or even a few months the way we're
seeing it now you see new consoles like
this every several years and if you want
to get a console that's more
future-proof you may be more concerned
with the actual specs inside if you want
to get certain games that are going to
be extremely intensive in four or five
years from now but back to the physical
size there's another thing you should
know obviously the controllers are
different sizes but the PlayStation 4
obviously way smaller a bit lighter very
similar actually to the PlayStation 3
slim in terms of size and weight then
the Xbox looks a lot like a VCR it's not
the same shape it's more of an actual
box whereas the ps4 is a parallelogram
technically but then the PlayStation has
a built-in power brick the Xbox doesn't
so you have to include an additional
power brick to plug it into the wall not
a big deal for a lot of people but when
you unbox these things and notice the
boxes way bigger on the Xbox the box is
way smaller on the PlayStation you get
more accessories with the Xbox larger
accessories with the Xbox and again
smaller package with the PlayStation in
terms of actual video output capability
and resolution as you guys know I'm a
big fan of pixels I like a lot of pixels
and I picked up that 4k TV that you guys
were recommending to me on Twitter you
might be able to see it in the frame
right now neither of these consoles
right now will actually output native 4k
you can't really game in 4k and a lot of
that will depend on the games that later
support 4k as well as a software /
firmware update that will enable these
consoles to at least display their user
interface on a 4k display in that native
4k resolution if you're concerned about
4k at all I have a 4k resolution and 4k
video explained video right below that
like button if you want to check any of
that out and if you're concerned about
why I like pixels so much that video
will help you out right now neither
these are 4k capable consoles but if
they're future-proof as
we know they are hopefully those updates
will come around very soon but the last
thing I want to talk about which is
really I guess the most important part
of the comparison between these two
consoles and even if you're not a big
gamer like me or if you are a huge gamer
and are really concerned about
purchasing one or the other you're going
to want to know more about the
philosophy behind the companies that are
pitching these to you and what they're
good for and what they're designed for
so if you start with the Xbox one it's
obviously a much larger physical console
and I guess the word console better
describes what the Xbox one is all about
this is from Microsoft they are trying
to take over with the Xbox one your
entire living room this isn't just a
game console but obviously with the
feature set and with all the different
things it's designed to do it'll do way
more than just a game console it'll take
over your cable box it's basically
designed to be the only thing plug into
your TV it doesn't want to live next to
any other box on the PlayStation side
from Sony you're going to see this is
really just made for gaming by gamers
it's really a purely gaming console
that's all it does and it's perfectly
content to live next to an Xbox or any
other boxes you probably already have
sitting underneath your TV this is just
gaming first and you'll see reflecting
all the software updates that come out
to these consoles this is going to get
updates that are for gaming because of
the gaming experience whereas the Xbox
is going to get updates for gaming stuff
it's going to get updates for other
sorts of firmware and software features
and your TV features and your web
browsing features and all sorts of
things like that
besides gaming now the ps4 does have web
browsing and it does have some other
features but again everything associated
with PlayStation Network and the ps4
just gaming stuff purely gaming now if
you're a gamer hardcore gamer you might
like that or you might think you know
certain launch titles like Forza 5 which
I picked up for the Xbox one are better
for just what you want to do so you
might pick up the Xbox one just for that
launch title but at the moment peer
gaming more than just game if you take a
look at the Sony Playstation 4 ads and
all the different things that Sony is
putting into the launch of the ps4 and
it's been very
successful so far you'll see that it's
all about gaming and obviously the games
and the exclusive launch titles and all
the gaming experience if you look at the
ads for from Microsoft the Xbox one
you'll see way more than just gaming
you'll see the TV stuff you see the
motion-activated stuff to see the Kinect
stuff you see the web browsing stuff you
see the TV stuff you'll see a whole lot
more being packed into this package
which you may like or you may dislike
depending on if you want to pay the
extra hundred dollars or if you don't
want the PlayStation Eye or the Kinect
there's a whole bunch of different more
factors that I plan on going way more in
depth into in the very near future so
basically what I'm saying here is I'm
planning on giving you guys as much
detailed content about these two
consoles and how they end up fitting
into my life and which one I end up I
guess choosing as soon as I can so it
sounds weird saying I promise to play a
lot of video games but that's basically
what I'm doing for you guys and we'll
see how that ends up going and maybe if
you guys want to give some common
suggestions below for some games that I
should play on each of these I already
have four as I already have Need for
Speed FIFA is on the way I'm ready
playing NBA 2k14 let me know what you
guys were thinking down in that comment
section below and I'll definitely get
around to checking it out but this is
the Xbox one and the ps4 more videos on
the way subscribe if you want to see
more videos like it thank you for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next one